exacto estamos hablando efectivamente de
un tipo de población en general de
origen de clase media si se puede
indicar así aunque nunca sabemos bien
qué queremos decir grosso modo urbanos
educados en la universidad y que tenían
a veces incluso una proyección
profesional o empresaria en su lugar de
origen esto es una vez más llegan aquí
para ver qué se puede hacer y
efectivamente
cuentan con un capital humano un capital
social de redes de conocimiento de
quienes ya están aquí o en su país de
origen o en otras partes
y hay un pensamiento un poco más y no lo
digo de manera peyorativa estratégico es
decir vengo acá veo trato de justamente
generar un espacio que me convenga que
me sirva que corresponda a mis
expectativas pero si esto no se produce
puedo mudarme de provincia puedo buscar
otro país de inmigración o incluso
retornar a mi país porque tal vez puedo
haber dejado un poco un pie afuera por
las dudas para ver qué pasa muchos
también circulan y mantienen vínculos
incluso profesionales o financieros con
el by origen o guardan
propiedad de alguna manera es el nuevo
migrante no digo que toda la población
que se mueve por el mundo o sea de estas
características pero hay este tipo de
persona móvil exacto que lleva su
capital móvil y ese capital es
justamente una vez más conocimiento de
idiomas este
a conocimiento de materias que son
exportables a cualquier sociedad desean
informática en marketing entonces yo
tampoco quiero dar una imagen homogénea
porque hay una enorme diversidad pero es
gente justamente que tiene esta
posibilidad yo diría de elegir entonces
es ahí donde también la provincia de
québec juega tiene que jugar ese rol de
seducción es decir no solo suscitar el
interés hacia quebec sino que también la
gente se quede y no todos los
inmigrantes que emigran aquí
se quedan para siempre de acuerdo ahora
entrando de lleno a la encuesta como tal
que usted la tituló no se si
definitivamente o por el momento la
integración social y económica de los
latinoamericanos en que ve que esa era
la intención de su investigación en que
se diferencia esta encuesta profesor
armón y de una encuesta que hace
estadísticas canadá por ejemplo bueno
justamente yo uso mucho los datos de la
agencia federal de estadísticas si son
extremas extraordinariamente útiles
pero nos faltaba creo yo justamente este
perfil que va a buscar
por un lado algunos elementos más
específicos pero también de modo general
lo que la gente piensa o quiere o supone
o evalúa entonces
hacíamos preguntas como
como de qué manera usted considera
satisfactorio y satisfactoria su vida
familiar social laboral etcétera
entonces con escalas de conformidad uno
puede mostrar después tiene una
tendencia hacia tal o cual posición
mayor o menor satisfacción de vida vamos
a llamarla así está después también
todas cuestiones sobre identificaciones
usted se siente más de aquí más de su
país de origen más latinoamericano con
quién tiene relación amistosa en el
trabajo gente de su propia comunidad
queremos ver si el latinoamericano por
ejemplo un poco se queda entre entre los
suyos culturalmente o lingüísticamente
hablando o si se abre al resto de la
sociedad entonces son factores que tiene
que ver con con la vida de todos los
días y también con la manera en que el
inmigrante mismo percibe su a su
trayectoria y sus experiencias